de tous les juifs qui vivent en france
dont majorité mais pas tous - das sont
français de nationalité
les trois quarts vont échapper à la
déportation et à la mort ce qui signifie
pso facto qu'un quart mourra dans les
camps nazis ou au cours des transports
ou dans les différentes prisons et camps
d'internement
si l'on compare avec les principaux pays
d'europe la france s'en tire évidemment
extrêmement bien on a souvent mis en
avant des facteurs de type géographique
notre pays est très grand il est il est
très grand par rapport à la quantité
d'allemands qui l'occupent 550 mille
kilomètres carrés c'est pas si simple
pour l'occupant allemande le quadrillé
la zone sud n'est pas occupé jusqu'en
novembre 1942 on sait qu'elle assurera
un refuge provisoire mais refuse tout de
même à des dizaines de milliers de juifs
français
mais ce facteur géographique n'est pas
déterminant ce qui semble déterminant au
vu des derniers travaux des historiens
français notamment de jacques semelin
c'est que dans leurs efforts pour se
sauver les juifs français et les juifs
qui vivaient en france qui n'étaient pas
français ont rencontré un milieu
favorable leurs efforts je le répète ils
se sont sauvés eux mêmes mais leurs
efforts ont été vains dans un autre
milieu nos efforts pour construire parce
que la société française dans son
immense majorité à partir de 1941 n'est
pas du tout favorable à la politique
antisémite du maréchal pétain absolument
pas et même une partie de la police ce
qui fait que les différentes techniques
utilisées par les juifs de france pour
survivre la fabrication de faux papiers
par exemple le fait de se réfugier dans
les zones rurales de se disperser
largement pour éviter d'être concentrés
dans les mêmes régions a pu porter ses
fruits
un certain nombre de réseaux de
solidarité se
ont mis en place dont ont bénéficié les
juifs de france
a contrario je dirais l'exemple en
dynamique de l'exemple français
c'est l'exemple néerlandais la
communauté juive d'amsterdam notamment
puisque c'était la plus importante
vive est refermée sur elle-même
il y avait relativement peu de contacts
avec avec la communauté la communauté
hollandaise
ce qui fait que lorsque les allemands
occupent les pays en mai 1940 les juifs
vont être une proie facile
ils vivent dans leur quartier ils sont
très facilement dénombrés et ils ne
pourront pas compter sur la seule grille
de la solidarité de leurs concitoyens
parce que les réseaux nécessaires n'ont
pas été mis en place
on ne verra pas comme en france par
exemple les colles les instituteurs les
associations de parents aider les
enfants juifs à s'inscrire dans les
écoles avec les autres où on l'a on ne
verra pas non plus des fonctionnaires de
police
prévenir à l'avancé des raf
non tout ça n'existera pas je dirais que
c'est un petit peu la rançon de la
politique communautaire de ce point de
vue là qui s'est imposé dans la hollande
dans les pays bas de
l'entre-deux-guerres cette espèce de
développement séparé on n'est pas
antisémite mais enfin les juifs vivent
entre eux les néerlandais que chrétiens
vivent entre eux en france vous le savez
le maître mot de la république saturé
telle assimilation l'intégration
complète
c'est très fort c'est très fort et du
coup ces juifs de france que l'on peut
que l'on peut pas repérer il parle
français parfaitement ils sont là depuis
fort longtemps
leurs enfants vont dans les écoles ils
connaissent les y connaissent leurs
quartiers connaissent des commerçants
ils connaissent des concierges
ils connaissent tous les relais sociaux
dans leur entourage pour eux ça va être
finalement faisable d'échappée
d'échapper au massacre
c'est moins vrai des juifs étrangers à
cause de quelque chose c'est seulement
parce qu'ils sont arrivés très tard ils
ont gardé un accent très fort et reste
concentré notre
dans des quartiers de paris fixé autour
de métiers traditionnels chez eux
et évidemment ils ont ils ont ils
disposent beaucoup moins de ses relais à
l'intégration dans la population
française
[Musique]